e aí
nem toda criança elefante super-herói
é mas as crianças que nascem
fragilizados
os doentes elas têm um apego maior a
imagem do super-herói e comigo não
poderia ser diferente de uma família de
6 irmãos e cinco irmãos comigo seis eu
nasci a mais fraca nasce com um problema
de coordenação motora demorei para falar
eu nasci com dislexia e dislalia e
disgrafia
hoje com seis anos de idade a minha casa
pega fogo meus pais não estavam em casa
eu tinha seis o meu irmão de cinco e
minha irmã de um e a gente estava sendo
cuidado por uma babá que estava
estendendo a roupa no fundo de casa
devido à fumaça ela não conseguiu entrar
para nos salvar eu para imagem de um
super-herói que eu tinha desde criança
que era o super-homem pensei vou salvar
minhas irmãs tenta e abrir a porta não
consegui comecei a dar soco achando que
deus vai me dar força do super-homem e
eu iria quebrar aquela porta golpeei
várias vezes até minha mão se desse
aguentar de sangue
eu saí para pedir ajuda as pessoas que
entraram dentro de casa cada vez que
saíram eu esperava que tivesse
carregando nos seus braços a minhas
irmãs mas sempre saía com alguma coisa
dentro de casa muitas delas até
saquearam minha casa naquele momento
e aí o corpo de bombeiro e acabou
salvando a minhas irmãs
e além de todos os traumas acabei
passando por outros novos devido e sem
eu não queria mais ter contato com ser
humano e não acreditavam mais um
super-herói e
e foi apresentado por uma psicóloga e
ela me apresentou o batman como fonte
então aos 10 passou um tempo
e aí
aí passou um tempo e meu pai acaba
ficando com câncer
oi e eu acabo me motivando ele a não
desistir do tratamento cansa ele passa
por cinco estágios a negação a raiva a
barganha onde entre as promessas a
depressão e aceitação todos passam por
esse estágio dependendo da velocidade ou
da intensidade de cada um e da sua fé e
o pai contentou em depressão eu acabei
motivando ele em e naquele dia eu fiz
uma promessa eu entrar debate nos
hospitais
e foi feita uma pesquisa no estados
unidos com três grupos de criança e o
primeiro grupo todos tinham que passar
por uma missão eles tem que fazer um
trabalho aonde tem os sabotadores ao
redor deles chocolate e tablets
videogames e outros brinquedos o
primeiro grupo de criança uma caixa de
som fazia assim roberto você precisa
completar sua missão maria você precisa
completar sua missão era falado o nome
das crianças e todas falharam na sua
missão o segundo grupo foram montados
grupos menores de crianças aonde cada
grupo foi dado um nome específico e era
um mesmo teste grupo alfa você precisa
completar a sua missão grupo delta você
precisa completar sua missão todas as
crianças falharam
e no terceiro grupo as crianças poderiam
escolher roupa de super-herói um
super-herói que quisesse e e continuava
a caixa de som emitindo mulher-maravilha
você precisa completar a missão
super-homem ou se precisa completar sua
missão as únicas crianças que
completarão sua missão foi as crianças
estavam vestido de batman
bom então se uma criança vestida de bati
nela se torna mais perseverante porque o
batman convencer elas de fazer um
tratamento não pode dar resultado ou não
poderia dar resultado
e no meu trabalho eu enfrento várias
dificuldades porque eu não trabalho com
recreação o meu trabalho é usar imagem
do batman mais fiel e fazer com que uma
criança que além de tratamento do câncer
ela enfrenta outro tratamento outra
doença que a depressão e eu tenho que
fazer com ela com que ela volte a querer
fazer o tratamento da quimioterapia e
nesse meu trabalho encontro duas coisas
extremamente difíceis uma é quando a
criança se recupera do câncer mas aquele
prazo de cinco anos onde pode voltar a
doença acaba voltando e ela tem que
lidar com toda aquela dor e desespero de
novo sabendo que ela vai passar
enfrentar tudo aquilo que ela já
enfrentou eu tenho que voltar a falar
para criança fazer o tratamento e torna
muito mais desgastante a minha parte
emocional
oi e a segunda é quando um pai ou uma
mãe entre em contato comigo ou até o
hospital dizendo que eu tenho que voltar
e e pedir para ela voltar a fazer o
tratamento porque se a criança não
aceitar alá é mandada se retirar do
hospital para morrer em casa eu sei que
se eu falhar essa criança vai morrer por
desistência em cima de tudo que eu já
estudei e venho estudando tudo pnl
rapport inteligência emocional que eu
acabei desenvolvendo uma coisa ea
coloquei o nome de ciência do batman a
ciência do batman definir e três pilares
medo raiva e dor quando tu tem esses
três elementos e mostra para pessoa como
tu pode trabalhar entender isso acaba
adquirindo duas coisas da pessoa que tu
está trabalhando
a confiança e esperança e quando tu tem
confiança e esperança tu consegue uma
coisa mágica tô consegue fazer com que
ela volte a lutar
um suplemento para ele não bate mas
quando crescer quero ver o batman para
crescer em todos vai ter que melhorar o
irá coisa tu vai ter que obedecer os
médicos pelo menos eu alinho tudo que o
médico fizer vai deixar vai começar o
treinamento hoje eu sou o batman tá bom
eu vou te visitar e vou fazer os testes
sobre isso tá coloquei contigo tá vai
ter que eu sou forte passo difícil até
rápido aí no hospital são josé onde eu
faço o trabalho com crianças tecnologia
e para mim um grande orgulho quando eu
sou chamado para algumas missões e eu
descobri que tem um artista que nem tem
uma pessoa que tens uma obra muito linda
a radioterapia pode chegar nos anos
recentes luiz henrique esse correr essa
massa aqui
o trabalho super bacana nosso amigo pode
ficar tranquilo aqui tanto que houve não
é o desde pequeno eu prometi presente de
hoje mais uma mentira falácia de novo da
costa
e aí
e eu não sei que eu fazer isso é
oi gente tava indo embora e aí me
falaram que tu falou estava no hospital
ele está lutando agora contra outro
vilão ele tá um pouco diferente ele tá
aqui ó
e aí gordinho tá mais velho cabelo
crescendo né a gente tem um vídeo cara
junto tu lembra esse vídeo do bem
pequenininho tinha três anos e da área
de é só que a gente assim a gente já tem
uma intimidade a gente já a gente vai
ficar sem as máscaras né esse aqui é
guerreira
e esse aqui também o guerreiro o pai
dele é guerreira que o herói meu pai
herói que ele também é de roupa para é a
vontade de vencer sabia disso sabia
disso é
15 linhas agora samuel 5 anos
oi gente decide também é
e aí
e com que atualmente não pode falar para
mim falou seus outro batman
olá eu sou o outro fátima
e eu antes de fazer o trabalho debate
mas já fazia trabalho nos hospitais esse
tipo de palhaço com crianças com câncer
e outras doenças e quando eu fiz um
treinamento com uma ong a pessoa estava
em cima de um palco ele disse o seguinte
vocês precisam aprender duas coisas não
se apeguem e não creem vínculo e no
começo eu acreditei naquilo mas hoje não
acredito não se apegar e não cria
vínculo é carinho e carinho não cura o
que cure amor e quando a gente dá amor a
gente se machuca nesse vídeo deixou bem
claro que eu trabalho ele não é só no
hospital em casa vídeo conferência é um
trabalho que vai mais além
e o pai dele entrou em contato comigo
falando que o flamengo já tava com sete
anos e o terceiro câncer e falou que ele
estava muito ruinzinho nessa mensagem só
que eu conheço o pai do painel eu sei
que esse muito ruinzinho é ele tá
morrendo e eu falei para ele nessa
mensagem que eu não poderia ir porque eu
tava tendo uma crise de cálculo renal e
para quem já teve sabe como é que adora
quando eu soube que ele tava nessa fase
eu falei para ele que eu tava indo na
hora botei essa roupa e pesa 25 kg a
sensação térmica de 50 graus pedir para
minha esposa terwal carro
oi e eu já tinha dado uma máscara de
presente o bat hang mas acabo eu nunca
te dado para mim uma criança eu tirei a
minha capa comecei a cobrir ele ele
acorda olha para mim disse batman eu
sabia que tu vinha
e diz dos três anos de idade até o i7 se
eu tivesse falhado com essa criança
nesse exato momento que eu teria me
arrependido às vezes a gente não
consegue controlar tudo ele faleceu mas
eu não me arrependo de nada da luta que
eu tenho feito porque eu dei meu máximo
eu entreguei imagens que tem por cento
entreguei 110 por cento
e depois de eu ter colocado a minha dor
de lado e cuidado da dor do meu amigo eu
fui cuidar da minha é
é o que o batman representa para mim o
batman é mais do que um vigilante um
herói é um símbolo de esperança que
serve para recompensar a fé das pessoas
e mostrar que qualquer um pode fazer a
diferença numa situação de caos
e não é o câncer que faz isso é o
tratamento o tratamento desde criança
fraca faz perder cabelo faz o que o
ambiente ao redor dela não deixa um
cheiro agradável o ambiente bonito faz
ela sentir dor faz ela perder a
esperança
e aí o batman entra e faz com que uma
criança que perca a esperança volte a
encontrar um sentido na vida faça comer
mesmo perdendo ao fato e o gosto pela
comida e muitas vezes doendo para poder
engolir porque o batman não tem poderes
igual o super-herói ele precisa comer
para ser forte
o e muitos casos
e faz com que eu ver eu convenço a
criança amputar partes do corpo para
mostrar que a vida vale a pena ser
vivida porque a vida é linda e a gente
dá sonhos para essa criança e realize o
sonho delas conseguindo prótese ou até
um aniversário de 15 anos fazendo com
que ela dança com seu irmão
e aí
e eu falo de deus e uma criança de três
anos de idade falo de fé e esperança
e eu falo do batman para ela no seu
poder da sua força
g1
é mas as pessoas acham que eu sou
invulnerável mas eu sangro se tivesse um
aparelho que pudesse ler a minha alma a
minha alma tá aí a cheia de cicatrizes
eu faço visitas a 14 anos e só no
hospital de criciúma santa catarina tem
90 crianças e hoje aparece o brasil
inteiro e cada palestra que eu vou eu
visito hospital daquela cidade eu
entrego o meu número de celular para ela
para quando ela precisar ligar para mim
né
é a pergunta que eu faço para vocês é
qual o superpoder de vocês o que fez
você está aqui hoje só um medo que
derruba vocês vocês levantam todo dia
com uma fé inabalável porque cada um de
vocês é diferente pode ter-se criado na
mesma família mas os traumas de vocês o
que fizeram seis forte hoje eu não quero
que vocês sejam super-heróis eu quero
que vocês sejam super-humanos meu nome é
cristiano os a letra eu sou o batman do
brasil obrigado a
[Aplausos]